alors à l'hôpital quand vous vous
réveillez vous découvrez qui vous manque
deux jambes et un bras c'est l'horreur
et nous accueillons notre terrier du
samedi 20h ce soir Priscille Déborah
bonsoir
alors Priscille
à 12 ans quand votre petit frère meurt
votre vie devient un véritable enfer peu
à peu vous plonger dans une longue et
longue dépression qui vous poussera à
vous jeter sous les roues du métro pour
mettre fin à votre calvaire aujourd'hui
vous manque un bras deux jambes mais
vous n'avez jamais été aussi heureuse
vous avez même réalisé votre rêve de
toujours devenir artiste peintre à plein
temps alors Priscille vous racontez
votre histoire dans un livre publié aux
arènes intitulée la peine d'être vécue
et à 20h dans Salut les Terriens
bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
à 12 ans dans votre petit frère meurt
votre vie devient un véritable enfer peu
à peu vous plonger dans une longue et
longue dépression qui vous poussera à
vous jeter sous les roues du métro pour
mettre fin à votre calvaire aujourd'hui
il vous manque un bras et deux jambes
mais vous n'allez jamais été aussi
heureuse vous avez même réalisé votre
rêve de toujours devenir artiste peintre
à plein temps
vous êtes né le 22 juin 1974 à
Meudon-la-Forêt vous grandissez dans
l'Ouest parisien votre père travaille
dans une grande banque votre mère est
professeur de français latin
en 1977 n'est votre petit frère Éric
malheur il est atteint de mucoviscidose
ce qui vous empêche pas de passer de
beaux moments avec lui vous chantez tous
les deux et quand il est fatigué il
s'arrête il vous regarde chanter en
souriant ça reste parmi les plus beaux
moments de votre vie oui tout à fait
parce que c'est la période de l'enfance
c'est plein de petits moments de douceur
de joie de joie simple en fait alors
dans la famille on souffre en silence
votre mère ne vous prend pas dans ses
bras elle reste froide et distante avec
vous parfois quand on vous envoie chez
votre grand-mère vous le vivez mal vous
vous sentez mise à l'écart les parents
ont voulu me protéger et donc on m'a dit
que en fait mon frère allait mourir
voilà ce qu'on veut être la
mucoviscidose maintenant on l'a guérit
un peu mieux mais là à l'époque il
savait qu'il allait pas vivre longtemps
et mon frère en fait le stade est aussi
qu'il allait mourir enfin ça c'est
incroyable enfin ses enfants malades en
fait qui savent qu'ils vont mourir et en
fait j'étais un peu la seule exclu du
secret entre guillemets alors la maladie
d'Eric progresse la nuit c'est quand
même que tout vous réveille il est là
dites-vous sur le palier les yeux
mi-clos le torse déformé par la toux en
fait je vois son corps qui est en train
de se transformer et en fait il commence
à avoir le vent tout gonflé et il vient
tout maigre un peu comme les enfants du
tiers-monde en fait et comment savoir si
le teint qui vient jaune le blanc des
yeux qui devient jaune
Eric se fatigue de plus en plus vite il
s'essouffle en mangeant personne donc ne
vous explique la gravité de la situation
vous sentez un petit peu exclu du secret
qui livre aux parents et Eric et un jour
en vacances en Auvergne
Eric fait une hémorragie votre mère part
à l'hôpital le lendemain votre père les
rejoint il oublie de vous emmener vous
courrez derrière la voiture et là il
finit par vous prendre à bord et vous
emmène avec lui à l'hôpital et quand
vous arrivez à l'hôpital il vous laisse
sur le parking
il rentre dans l'hôpital vous êtes là
vous klaxonnez cinq fois mais personne
s'occupent de vous quoi
c'est quelqu'un qui est en fait
extrêmement émotif enfin comme beaucoup
d'hommes en fait mais tu gardes beaucoup
de choses à l'intérieur et du coup en
fait pourtant il savait parce qu'il
avait eu un coup de fil le matin comme
quoi en fait mon petit frère était
décédé et du coup en fait tellement
émotif qui m'a oublié mais voilà c'est
pas par méchanceté c'est juste que il
était dans son émotion
Eric meurt donc il avait 9 ans vous 12
et là vos parents sombres dans le
mutisme votre père regarde la télé tout
le temps votre mère corrige ses copies
elle donne aussi des cours de catéchèse
va beaucoup à la messe elle se réfugie
dans la religion catholique
chacun va casser ses occupations et
personne ne parle de rien et en fait on
vit avec un truc très pesant comme ça
voilà tout le monde sait tout le monde
pense à mon frère tout le temps et on en
parle jamais et moi à chaque fois que
j'essaie d'en parler ma mère elle
s'effondre en pleurs en disant arrête de
me faire souffrir et tout ça donc je me
dis on est maintenant je me tirais et
vous vous écoutez en cachette les
cassettes que vous aviez enregistré avec
votre frère quand vous chantiez tous les
deux
vous donner un orexique vous descendez à
45 kg vous n'avez plus vos règles en
fait vous cherchez l'attention vous
voulez qu'on s'occupe de vous et
personne s'occupe de vous oui puis le
côté aussi où je suis survivante quelque
part je pense que c'est une espèce de
culpabilité à vivre que j'ai parce que
mon frère est mort et pourquoi pas moi
en classe le premier vous prenez des
cours de peinture aux Beaux-Arts
après votre école de commerce vous êtes
embauché comme assistante de production
dans une grande société de cinéma vous
occupez du l'agenda du patron on fait de
la dactylographie des photocopies c'est
pas très marrant en fait si vous voulez
je voulais devenir artiste peintre mais
dans la famille ça se fait pas c'est pas
un métier et mon père en fait j'avais
dit écoute fais une école de commerce et
après tu feras ce que tu veux dans l'art
et donc en fait après je me suis un peu
perdue c'est à dire que je me suis dit
bon peut-être que le cinéma pourrait
réconcilier les deux voilà la reine
commerce et puis finalement je me
retrouve assistante de prod quoi
vous faites la fête vous laissez séduire
par des types plus ou moins
fréquentables jusqu'à ce que vous
rencontriez Tristan voilà ça va mieux
oui c'est mon ex-mari qui est stable qui
s'est entouré me protéger
qui me respecte aussi par rapport à tous
les autres hommes que j'ai rencontrés
avant
et avec qui était bon vivant aussi donc
on passe des moments voilà des moments
d'une petite fille qui s'appelle Zoé
mais ce qui est assez triste c'est que
vous vivez mal l'arrivée de Zoé vous
dites sa présence m'empêche de peindre
en fait si vous voulez ce qui s'est
passé c'est quand j'ai isolé j'ai fait
une dépression post-partum qui s'est
transformé en grosse dépression j'avais
30 ans en fait et là j'ai fait un peu un
bilan sur ma vie en fait j'étais pas du
tout à ma place je t'aime mais qu'est-ce
que je fous là
je suis pas heureuse dans ce métier là
je me sens pas du tout mère de famille
et en fait j'étais une mère dépressive à
mort qui me pensait que à une chose si
vous la rejoindre son lit il y avait
plus de projet plus de désir plus rien
je voulais voir personne à consulter des
psys résultats vous pourrez
d'anxiolytique d'antidépresseurs ça vous
aboutit et là les premières pensées
suicidaires apparaissent quand vous
apprenez le suicide d'un ami qui avait
perdu une petite sœur dans sa genèse et
en fait moi ça fait deux ans que je suis
en dépression j'arrive pas à être
soigner correctement et j'en peux plus
d'être une loque à la maison mon mari me
dit mais bouge-toi un peu j'en ai marre
tu es en train de tout détruire autour
de toi me Veron qui me disent mais
essaye de travailler un peu tu sais il
faut toujours voilà la vie c'est pas
facile il faut accrocher il faut y aller
et tout ça j'ai l'impression d'être
compris plusieurs personnes en fait au
bout d'un moment je me dis il vaut mieux
que disparaisse plutôt que d'être un
poids pour les gens vous foncez chez un
chez un psy ce jour-là vous êtes en
avance vous êtes rongé par l'angoisse
vous arrachez les cheveux par poignet
c'est très grave vous montez sur le bord
de la fenêtre vous allez sauter et le
psy vous retient inextremis en fait
c'est un restaurateur qui m'a vu en bas
et qui appelle tout de suite le psy
voilà c'était une première tentative
tous les jours vous avez ces pulsions
suicidaires par exemple quand vous êtes
dans votre bureau il y a une grille en
bas et vous pensez sauter sur la grippe
ou vous empaler sur la grille quoi c'est
vraiment très très fort très vous êtes
tourmenté par ça oui je cherche par tout
moyen en finir mais voilà me faire
emballer j'ai quand même un peu peur de
souffrir donc je voudrais un truc
radical soft et après on en parle plus
et là vous choisissez le métro alors à
l'hôpital quand vous vous réveillez vous
découvrez qui vous manque deux jambes et
un bras c'est l'horreur
en fait déjà avant j'étais en dépression
mais je pouvais encore me cacher
derrière une apparence de voilà de
filles pas trop moche et tout ça et là
tout d'un coup je me retrouve comme une
espèce de ver de terre avec ce corps
atroce et en plus complètement encore
suicidaire quoi je me dis il est temps
d'être juste autonome pour après aller
en Suisse ou en Belgique me faire
euthanasier alors votre mère vient vous
voir elle vous dit il faut que tu pries
et puis une fois habillé ça se verra
plus donc elle vous propose de cacher en
fait tout ça plutôt que de l'accepter ou
de vivre elle n'est pas d'un grand
secours vous êtes transférant
psychiatrie et là c'est votre belle-mère
donc qui vient vous voir avec une
bouteille de Pessac Léognan et un opéra
et vous lui dites je veux partir en
Suisse pour me faire euthanasier elle
vous convaincre vous donner un nom
en fait c'est la première qui me dit ok
mais dans un an et à ce moment là on y
va ensemble ne faites pas ça seul là
vous apprenez à vous accepter à vous
rééduquer vous rentrez chez vous vous
retrouvez Tristan et Zoé et vous décidez
de vous séparer de Tristan vous dites la
femme dont il était tombé amoureux
n'était pas celle que j'étais vraiment
en fait si vous voulez quand il vous
arrive quelque chose comme ça en fait si
on en ressort et que tout d'un coup on a
une nouvelle énergie de vie c'est comme
une seconde naissance c'est comme si je
vivais pour la première fois mais que je
m'étais un peu moi-même fait naître en
fait et j'ai un appétit de vie mais
comme j'ai jamais eu jusqu'à présent et
j'ai envie de parcourir le monde j'ai
envie de peindre voilà toute la journée
de faire des expos à droite à gauche
elle est à New York à Berlin au Danemark
et là en fait il arrive pas à me suivre
quoi il comprend pas ce qui se passe
effectivement vous commencez à faire à
ce moment-là tout ce que vous n'avez pas
eu le culot de fer quand vous étiez
valide et vous commencez à exposer vos
peintures c'est enfin vous faites ce que
vous aviez toujours eu envie de faire à
ce moment-là rien m'est impossible en
fait et même draguer des mecs en fait
même les plus beaux qui soient que
jamais
Frédéric il est super vraiment
et c'est vrai que voilà je m'empêche de
rien en fait alors voilà on vous écoute
de prothèse haute technologie et vous
avez cette phrase sur extraordinaire
tout pour ne plus voir mon corps comme
un désastre mais comme celui de la Vénus
de Milo c'est génial
alors
mi-temps après vous vivez au bord de la
mer avec Frédéric vous peignez au moins
deux heures tous les matins et vous avez
un nouvel enfant avec Frédéric qui
s'appelle Suzanne
extraordinaire histoire le livre
s'appelle la peine d'être vécu et c'est
publié aux arrêts merci de votre
commande et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de Inna larditube abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu